what god what a sick shot it's a visual
effect Oh turns out it looks super Jake
this is a very special one we're
reacting to our videos thank you to our
sponsor ray Khan for bringing you
today's episode stay tuned to the end of
the video to learn how to save 15% on
your first order hi welcome back to
another episode of VFX artists react the
little baby's all grown up and off to
college so I can come back down here and
film summer videos with you guys for
those of you who don't know corridor
digital is a channel that's existed for
90 years now have over a billion views
and we make VFX videos there been a ton
of comments asking us to actually review
the videos that we've made let's jump in
shadow of mordor so this was a video we
did five years ago this is the only
other official live-action Lord of the
Rings video in existence outside of the
movies in The Hobbit
for those of you who do not recognize
him that little blue orc there is none
other than Clint rap guides are humor
he's getting Aladdin punched genie
number-one mistake we made it this movie
is giving all the slaves the same wig
[Laughter]
that fish there is not a real fish we
originally didn't know if we're gonna do
the fish or not oh yeah so he's holding
a knife and then later we replaced it
with a fish and it's a pretty convincing
fish no one ever realized it wasn't real
by the way there's like a little bit of
force perspective in that shot he's not
that much taller than Clint he's a
little bit closer to the camera and
Clint's a little bit further away so it
makes him look a lot bigger
so he's swinging at nothing Clint is
like a solid succeed back anytime you
see sword combat in film somebody it
stablish Lee in out horse Weis but the
thing that did in the animation for the
game shadows morale which I loved I had
never seen before was people get stabbed
and in the sorbets get pushed through
afterward doing that as an actual effect
is very very hard how do you stab
something into somebody and then push it
through them the answer to how you do
that is lots and lots and lots of work
oh man God what a six-shot said blade of
the tour right there it's all think it's
just the hilt that's real as he pulls it
out you motion track it and then you
track that in as a liquid emitter so
that's sword itself is actually where
the liquid is spawning yes you can see
it there as he's pulling it out it's
like actually emitting blood perfectly
and then I have it stopped emitting
blood the moment he stops moving and I
remember the rendering taking half an
hour per frame yeah the computer that
Wren made those particle effects on
basically had the power of a ps3 so if
you guys are on old computers there's no
excuses you can make this shot they'll
take a long time but you can make this
shot so do you guys remember how I did
the last shot where he gets his head cut
off I do
I do remember knew he filmed Billy aka
Italian in the background just swinging
his sword no one else is there
then he filmed Zen the King or here on a
green screen in the same spot yes then a
third element of the King sitting there
and then just spinning around in frame
so you can get his head actually
rotating in place we have once again
another beautiful real flow of
simulation from Ren I'd forgotten about
the fact that I basically pulsed it so
it's like you have one big pulse of
blood going up and then it stops and
then it goes on again as if it's in beat
with his heart but there's actually
something tracked underneath all the
blood there on both the body and the
head and it's like that little meaty
circle yes what I ended up doing is we
have a prop head that has a next step on
it i photo scanned it so I have a 3d
model of of these next stumps and I
render those as totally separate
elements that kind of cover up all the
masking and fun stuff that's making this
possible
[Music]
it's really grody attractive in space
onto this to the headstone actually
falls out but you just replace the face
of the stump with the Zen's face but
it's all works you know it's okay to
kill orcs and I think that's like the
message in this video
wawk wawk is look at that it's a baby G
and a baby n if you've never seen it
before every color repeats the same
exact actions until a future clone that
comes in potentially changes the course
of events thereby unlocking the past
clone so this is basically just a very
complicated clone video yes it comes
down to it will just have a playlist of
all the videos we talked about in this
video as a link in the description below
this is when like the most we could
afford for budget was buying five
different colored shirts so the lot were
shooting in one of our friends II grew
weed and we helped them move to like the
new lot so he gave us a big bag of weed
but what we'd use that weed for us not
for smoking but instead of going on
Craigslist and traded it for airsoft
guns same school kids don't do drugs
just honestly because apparently I won't
talk about the three levels of camera
motion here you have a static camera
where it's on a tripod unmoving such as
the camera right here it's something
three of us on the couch doing a clone
with a static camera is the easiest way
to do that so that camera can fill me
here and it can fill me here and we can
just slice the frame in half and now
there's two of us next up you have a
nodal pan where the camera stays in one
spot but can pan and look around now
this gets a little bit trickier when
you're trying to do clone shots but not
that much trickier because you can still
track the shot and just stick part of
your frame back on and everything will
line up but then you have the third
level of camera motion which is the
hardest one to deal with for all types
of the effect shots and that's the
translational camera movement it's not
just panning and tilting in one spot
it's actually moving around the scene so
you're getting parallax the backgrounds
changing you're getting new perspectives
on things and that requires a
representation of your world in 3d so we
actually try to avoid that completely
we're doing this video one trick we're
doing here frequently is combining a
nodal move with a 3d move and what this
does is it gives the impression that
we're doing a much more complicated VFX
shot in the shot where the white neko
and purple neko run up to cover or we
start actually with a nodal move but
then as we pan away with the white clone
we transition that shot into a 3d camera
move because we're we begin chasing the
other one it's like the VFX shot ends
the moment you pan away exactly
how do you think we did the shot looks
so good about it except for two things
Sam where's your shadow you can see
quickly how he did it when the camera
starts to move you want to have one Sam
role attired another Sam hide behind it
if Sam the other Sam is a clone that's
film in a separate shot how do we get
him to interact with an object that's
from a different shot the solution is to
have Sam just kick in the air where the
tires supposedly is and he's just hidden
behind the tire so you don't actually
see him interact with it the 3d track of
you into the shots pretty solid there
because you're evidently rotoscoped out
and tracked into the second half of the
shot there right yes yep you can see
there's where Anam like glitches you can
also see white stripes up here under his
legs when he kicks the tire yeah and you
see fingers for a brief moment on the
side of the tire no what you don't see
any of that in action well maybe you do
I do definitely on your watching on your
phone you down alright so here is
probably my favorite video I've ever
worked on
fun fact we still had to make the shots
in the video too if you freeze frame on
Sam's look of joy there that's like real
joy because he had just made this shot
that we had tried and you'd missed
everyone so this video the most
challenging part about this was getting
the footage that we needed to see on the
other side of these portals I'd seen
other portal films up until this point
but no one ever really got the correct
perspective down to what you would
actually see on the other side of the
portal it's like a mirror
[Music]
so this shot in particular was alright
well we have a portal that's up above
and we have a portal that's on the side
so not only do we need a camera angle
that is up above on the bridge we need
to remember that we would actually be
able to see ourselves and so we had yeah
same choreography when it came to
filming those little plates you see
through the portals there how did the
basketball actually fall through the
portal well the funny thing is Nico
picks up nothing the basketball was the
film's plate later because I just I just
spun it on my finger against a green
screen later wrote up that out and place
it on top tracked it to Nico's finger
there we actually had real green screen
portal sized cut out yes attached to the
wall so that's how a Nico is able to be
rotoscoping here the basketball doesn't
become real in that shot until it's
about a foot away from touching the hoop
[Music]
this this shark here is one my favorite
shots how does Sam in one unbroken shot
here run through the portal and end up
physically on the other side of the
street so right here we wit pan out boom
we go to a new location so this new shot
right here everything except the portal
is CG so everything around here is fake
and Sam's just jumping through a hole in
a green screen I'm just jumping through
a hole in a green screen not only can
you see Sam run through the portal you
can see me run through the portal
holding the camera and then Sam has to
actually catch the basketball that's
gonna hook tat him I was the only one
who could throw the basketball accurate
enough to get Sam to catch it
Brenden if you didn't know this used to
be a mascot at basketball games oh my
god so he's super super good at
basketball in general that's why this is
all about basketball
[Music]
so this is a 3d model of me by the way I
just stood here like this when you
photoscan me amazing an Xbox Kinect
using an Xbox Kinect that's right on
also this is a ragdoll here and by the
crazy it's crazy thing about ragdolls is
you have to just kind like throw them
into the scene and hope it works out and
so I was through at once
didn't work out too much pressure
somehow need to get to be like a dunk
and then just magically like on my like
5th try the ragdoll this happened to
fall on the hand happen to hit where the
rim of the basketball hoop was and I
just I didn't touch it from that point
forward
so the basketball hoop heats actually be
interacted with it needs to be hit and
then needs to fall over so on set ran
just jumps up with this in the same
vertical and grabs the hoop and ganks
the whole thing down maybe that will be
died from that it used to be a mascot
like this like you're a professional
slam dunk
[Music]
I did not work on this video at all but
it is one of the best videos ever to
have graced the Internet this is also
one of the most disliked days on the
entire channel a lot of our video
inspiration just comes from learning it
to do an effect shot like a new
technology comes to us like oh we can do
animation we can do motion capture so
much easier now with the Kinect let's do
a motion capture video well it turns out
it looks super Jake the thing is that's
all actually every people dancing like
everyone actually did the move for their
smaller character yeah I just captured
by an Xbox Kinect I love these shots and
this is where things get dark and weird
and I think this is why most people
started just like in this video because
it went a really weird
yeah they eat the weak ones
[Music]
well the fun thing is like anytime we'd
shoot a video in LA well it looks like
San Andreas and it's realizing that we
could actually pair up a lot of the
stuff you see in game in GTA with what's
basically right outside our door with
this technology with the gimbal GoPros
is really what allowed us to do it we
had a stable tiny lightweight camera we
could put at the end of a boom hole we
could have a perfect third-person camera
that follows people everywhere and best
of all it was small enough to bring into
locations where you normally could not
film we're not acting like humans and
this were acting like GTA characters
yeah Jake nailed it but yeah watch the
guys in the background here they don't
know heroes oh that was not acting those
guys are actually like what so this
video was made possible from writing a
boosted board and so there I was reading
the Busan board I jumped off to be able
to go across the grass here and now I'm
waiting behind this car as Nico's wife
and baby mama comes rolling on the
ground you know please somebody hide
behind the pie look in the rear
windshield there if you just watch it
you can see rest then it immediately
cuts to a car chasing behind the Porsche
here I'm just jammed out the sunroof
trying not to fly out of the car using
the world's longest boom pull the sign
it's actually something I've always been
curious about so you guys actually shot
at the Los Angeles Gun Club but at the
beginning of this it says Los Santos
it's a visual effect in the game this
particular location exists and that's
two blocks away from our studio I took
the actual text that was there that said
Los Angeles gun club and I just
rearranged the letters how did you make
the team I think that one was custom I
think I had to make that my thing sticks
out those are real muzzle flashes by the
way no they're not I think no the bullet
casings were real the bullet cases
really basic muzzle flashes are faster
than cameras can capture every once in a
while huge shoot and we wouldn't see the
flash so I just read composite sometime
back
something I really want to point out
about our mentality here at quarter is
that like you don't have to make your
effects perfect it's it's fun and it's
better when your effects are really good
I'd say you took these effects to like
80 to 90 percent as opposed to like 95
to 100% mhm and they're good enough to
elicit the reaction we wanted to get out
of viewers which is like whoa that's
crazy
it's like GTA 5 in real life yeah like
the money fallen on the ground is just
like a simple little like simulation it
looks good enough it's really just about
understanding what your content is where
it's going who's watching it this is
this is a YouTube video the majority of
you guys watch our videos on phones so I
know that much so that means I know what
I can get away with here and you have
the time budget to really heavily
consider it's like we're making these
videos every other week you only had a
week to do the visual effects because we
spent a whole week filming it good times
we've made a lot of videos we have a
playlist of all the videos we just
talked about on the corridor channel
it's down in the description below
oddly enough a bunch of people don't
even know that we have a corridor
channel if you guys have seen some of
our work that you've really enjoyed and
want to know more about leave it in the
comments below and if we do this again
we'll check that out man so many
memories in all these videos I mean I
remember when we filmed shadow of Mordor
and I had to spend five hours every
morning in makeup so that I could just
be an orc all day on set you know what
would have been fantastic having a pair
of recon earbuds courtesy of today's
sponsor now while I already have a pair
now it would have really been great to
have a pair then because they have no
dangling wires or stems meaning that
they would have fit right into that orc
mask I could have been playing Lord of
the Rings music all day I mean heck I
remember way back in the day when the
set of clock blockers it would have been
great to have a pair of Rey Khan's back
again and we would have been able to
afford it because rate on earbuds are
about half the price of other premium
brands the only difference between raike
on earbuds and corridor videos is that
you're not gonna get a discount on your
corridor videos because they're already
free but if you go to buy a condo slash
corridor crew you'll get 15% off your
first purchase of recon earbuds what's
not to love about that dude we didn't
even talk about Boston Dynamics we'll
talk about Boston I think when we're
done with the second one which is coming
out very soon and what I'm Lily I
literally can see Clint working on right
now so there's no
and here's our little reaction screen
and then above it is Clint unbossed down
to